We're now starting test 7.
And we're on section two.
Let's see, problem
1 is on page 774.
So they say set x-- x is equal
to this-- 30, 31, 32, 33.
I haven't read the problem
yet, I'm just
drawing what they drew.
This is 32, 33, 34, 35 and 36.
Sets x and y are shown above.
How many numbers in set
x are also in set y?
Well hopefully it's fairly
straightforward.
Is 30 in set y?
No.
Then is 31 in set y?
32 is, right?
And so is 33.
1, 2, the answer is 2.
That's choice A.
Not too tough, huh?
All right, problem number 2.
If Peg traveled 10 miles in 2
hours, and Linda traveled
twice as far in 1/2 the
time-- So Linda
traveled twice as far.
So twice as far is 10 miles.
So she traveled 20
miles, right?
Times 2, that's all I did.
And they say, in 1/2 the time,
so she traveled 20 miles in 1
hour, right?
I just do the 1/2 here.
20 miles in 1 hour.
What was Linda's average speed
in miles per hour?
She did 20 miles in 1 hour.
Well that's 20 miles per hour.
And that's choice C.
Also not a difficult problem.
Not that you should feel bad if
you had it wrong, it's just
all about practice.
It's all about actually
reading the problem.
I know that might seem
a bit obvious,
but you'd be surprised.
You've even seen me make a
couple of mistakes by not
reading the problem properly.
OK, problem 3.
My cousin marked this up with a
black marker, so I only hope
that what I see is
what you see.
So let's see, x is equal to--
she did this when she was in
sixth grade.
So I'm very proud of her that
she was taking the SAT in
sixth grade.
But anyway, x is equal
to k times k minus 2.
Then x plus 1 is
equal to what?
[COUGH]
Excuse me. x plus 1
is equal to what?
So let's just add 1 to both
sides of this equation.
So x plus 1 is equal to k times
k minus 2 plus 1, right?
I just added 1 to both sides
of that equation, and that
equals k squared minus
2k plus 1.
And that is choice-- if I
can read this properly--
that is choice C.
k squared minus 2k plus 1.
Problem number 4.
I should have drank water before
starting this video,
but I will move forward and
complete what I have begun.
So they draw a graph that looks
something like that.
And then there's a line that
goes something like this.
And then they tell us--
what do they tell us?
They tell us, well it looks
like, it intersects at this
point, at y equals 1.
So this is the point,
0,1, right?
x is 0, so this is the x-axis.
This is the y-axis.
The figure above shows the graph
of a line of y equals ax
plus b where a and
b are constants.
Which of the following best
represents the graph of the
line 2a x plus b?
So let's draw it.
I'm not even going to look
at all the choices.
What would this look like?
So it's going to have the
same y intercept, right?
It's going to intersect
at the same point.
That's the y intercept.
Let me draw in this
peach color.
So it's going to intersect
right here.
And its slope is 2 times the
slope of the previous one.
So it's going to be even
a steeper slope.
So the line's going to look
something like this.
It's going to be twice as
steep, so it's going
to look like this.
All right?
And all I just have is that
same y intercept, right?
Because the b is still d, but
they've doubled the slope, so
it's going to go
up even faster.
And so, if you look at all the
choices, we can immediately
rule out all of the
choices that don't
have the same y intercept.
And the only choices that have
the same y intercept are
choices B and C, right?
Only those that intersect
at 0, 1.
And then between B and C, B is
steeper so B is going to be
our answer, right?
C is actually less steep
than this green line.
Choice C looks something
like this.
So its slope is less than A.
So it's not going to be choice
C, so it has to be choice B.
B goes through the same y
intercept and it is steeper
than our original green line.
So that's the answer,
choice B.
Next problem, problem 5.
OK, they drew us a triangle.
That's one side.
That's another side.
They have drawn this-- whoops.
I can't-- OK, there you go.
That's not as nice looking as
I would have liked, but you
get the point.
That's a right triangle.
They say that this is x.
And the figure above the
perimeter of the triangle is 4
plus 2 root 2.
What is the value of x?
So what is the value
of this side?
Well Pythagorean theorem, the
value of that side is the
square root of x squared
plus x squared.
So that equals, what?
The square root of 2x squared.
You can take the x out, right?
Square root of x squared
is just x.
So that equals x square
root of 2.
And they actually even tell
you that on the first page
of-- if you go back to page 774,
they tell you, you have a
45, 45, 90 triangle, it's
s square roots of 2.
But I like to solve
it every time.
So this is x, this is x, this
is x square root of 2.
So what's the perimeter?
It's x plus x plus x root 2.
So it's 2x plus x root 2.
That's the perimeter, right?
And they also tell us that,
that equals 4 plus
2 root to 2, right?
That's for the perimeter.
So you could just do
pattern matching.
You'd say well, this looks a
lot like x is equal to 2.
And it is, because if x is equal
to 2, this becomes a 2,
and then this becomes
a 4, right?
So that's our answer,
x is equal to 2.
And that is choice A.
Next problem.
Let me switch colors.
OK.
There's always something
for me to draw.
Well before I draw it, let
me read the question.
The scores on Tuesday's history
test for 16 students
are shown on the table above.
Sam was the only student
absent on Tuesday.
He'll take the test next week.
If Sam receives a 95 on the
test, what will be the median
score for the test?
OK.
So they give us a score and
number of students.
So I'm actually going
to write all this,
score and then number.
And so 1 kid got 100; two kids
got a 95; 90, four kids got
it; 85, 1 kid; 80, 3 kids; 75,
2 kids; 70, 2 kids; 65, no
kids; and then 60, 1 kid.
And then Sam comes along and
gets a 95 on the exam, right?
So before, there's only
2 kids who got a 95.
Now Sam comes along and there's
going to be 3 kids who
got a 95 on the exam.
So to figure out the median, all
I do is I list out all the
numbers, and then I pick
the middle number.
That's all the median is.
So one kid got 100.
3 kids got a 95: 95, 95, 95.
Four kids got a 90:
1, 2, 3, 4.
One kid got an 85.
Three kids got an
80: 80, 80, 80.
Two kids got a 75.
Two kids got a 70.
And one kid got a 60.
So how many does that total?
I could have just added this.
That's actually what
I should have done.
But it's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
So there's 17 kids.
So the median is going to be
the number that has eight
above it and eight below it.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, Bam!
That's the median, because
there's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6-- oh,
no, no, that's not the median.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, this
is the median: 85.
Because there's 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8 above it.
And there are 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8 below it.
So the answer is 85.
Before Sam came in there, then
the median actually would be--
you'd have one number
less here, so you'd
have to move it up.
So it'd probably be 90,
or it'd be an average.
But anyway, we know that
the median is 85.
And that is choice C.
See you in the next video.